former Senator told Biden he'd kicked
the [__] out of him then VP for getting
handsy with his wife if you want to get
this video ready by the way former
Senator Scott Brown recounted a threat
he made to President Joe Biden after an
alleged incident in 2010 when Biden got
too close to Brown's wife Brown stated I
told him I'd kick the [__] out of him uh
beat it beat and then I told him to stop
the incident took place during uh Brown
swearing ceremony with photographs
capturing Biden's hand position near
Brown's wife's posterior what posters
like butt is that what that means it's
like that you know the part that goes
outside
anger Outburst Brown also criticized
Biden's well-known touchy Behavior
mentioning an incident where actress Eva
Longoria had to guide Biden's hands away
from her breasts you can show that clip
as well White House film screaming in
June but play this clip and then play to
the podcast of him saying this with TMZ
go for it this is the clip
literally can't see his arm listen I can
see it at him sorry
literally can't see his arm no I see
three times he tapped her butt I mean
why would the guy lie why is he lying so
pause and go through go through what he
said on the podcast if you have it Rob I
don't know if you do or not okay let's
play this one here go for it
hair sniffing Gale or handy with Gail or
did I imagine yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
told him I'd kick the [__] out
I told him to stop so yes I think people
are irked out about all the hair
sniffing and things then we went
overseas and he especially took a long
inhale and I think women are skeeved out
by that that stuff and and you know he's
not a good guy you know him I mean
listen he's he's I did know him I I
spent quite a bit of time with him I I
enjoy this company but that's not Joe
Biden he is this you we all know the
signs Mike yeah my uh you know we all
know people who have dementia and and
have the beginning of Alzheimer's and
and you know he's got it I mean it's the
walk it's the way he's mumbling his
anger outbursts and you know it's it's a
shame uh that we can't do better as I
said uh in this great country but you
know a lot of people don't want to run
because of everything you're seeing now
yeah hey you know I might be imagining
this but did you when you were on the
herald radio with us probably seven
years ago when you got sworn in as
Senator was he like hair sniffing Gail
or handy with Gail or did I imagine yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I told him yeah but
but is it just boggles my mind that it's
just okay like he's been doing it
forever now that he's old people are
just like Eva Longoria video if you can
find it go for it you know what I mean
no pets like like is it unbelievable
that he's been getting away with it
forever how many videos of him this
one's awkward all right let me see him
all right this one's Awkward watch this
watch what she does Google watch this
one he's he just hit the side nipple
look at that yeah he's shopping he's
shopping for cantaloupe sir guys I don't
know no no this is to me can I be honest
with you go ahead this is kind of weak
honestly I think he should step his game
up I like presidents that grab him by
the [__] okay I got you don't don't
half-ass these hugs just go all in show
me one video go for it show me one I'm
actually not kidding no no Clinton
listen if I'm married to Hillary Clinton
and some young intern who's uh of age
and consensual wants to in the White
House go ahead buddy you want to grab
him by the whoo whoa let's go for it
yeah but if Biden should step his game
up stop [__] half-assing and maybe
touching a derriere
sleepy ass Joe grab a [__] titty
I'm your podcast tomorrow by the way
welcome to the South castle Yeah
Adam's crazy all jokes aside though how
many videos there dude there's
compilations of him not only grabbing
women like this sniffing kids touching
kids young 13 year old girls like this
hold on live on camera in the white
house while the vice president not
enough and he needs to do more I'm being
serious he's touching and smelling
children at him yeah the kids gets away
with it and he gets away with it bro
like that's that just shows you when
people are like these Elites they're not
protected there's no pedophilia the guy
is on camera smelling and clutching
girls that are looking like look at that
girl that that one photo right there uh
Rob the one look at that like if and
look at the father doesn't give a [__]
Pat look at what this I want to find
this girl and interview her excuse me
what did you feel when Joe Biden was
smelling you when you were 14 years old
it's disgusting and if anything that his
his daughter Rob his daughter wrote in
that uh in her diary that they found at
the Airbnb by the way the dumbest family
ever Hunter leaves laptops in repair
shops and Hunter uh Joe Biden's daughter
left her diary at an Airbnb then just
hold on the project Veritas people uh
they had it you know what she said my
father was taking baths and showers with
me at an inappropriate age what does
that say to you Adam he's a disgusting
old man but guess what oh he has
dementia oh it's old Joe oh he's a
grandfather he's cute no it's disgusting
bro let me tell you something go ahead
how many politicians have you met in
your life
um the one a couple I'll say no you've
met way more than three okay let me tell
you something go ahead Adam there's a
something that all politicians do and
that is they say get out there shake
some hands and kiss some babies we all
know that they all do it now the problem
with Joe these days is that he's shaking
babies and kissing hands he's a little
dementia he doesn't know which one's
going on but they all do it bro if you
want to freeze frame you taking a
picture with a kid yeah it's always
going to look weird so anytime that you
want to make up a story you'll find no
doubt is he creepy yes is Trump creepy
for sure are they all [__] doing
weird stuff for sure time so be be an
equal opportunity okay and call him wait
wait time out there is no way in hell
you are gonna compare any other random
politician that who the hell has a
compilation of of what he's done in the
White House
kissing babies and saying hi and waving
and [__] no other president in the
history of presidents has that much
footage of him smelling little kids
period or rubbing on people's nipples
how much have you partied with Hunter
Biden be honest I have never parted with
them I tried but you never relaxed no
but that see that kid stuff is
disgusting I'm sorry there's a there's a
there's a couple Lots will set right
there back and forth there's a couple
things to be thinking about
um anytime you have a reputation of
overly of being done it's it's pretty
real you can't think of a lot of stories
of politicians kissing babies and
anyone's use it to be as creepy as this
guy does it just very very this is
in regards to Trump and creepy Trump and
creep you want to call them player
you're going to call him a Salesman you
want to call them all that stuff totally
fine you want to call them is that
businesses go bankrupt totally fine
creepy is not a word that's going to
catch on with him
um this is a guy that's a player like
Biden's not a player Trump is a real
life player he's had a lot of beautiful
women you can criticize criticize him
there all day long so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you
foreign